14 blessés dont un grave c'est le bilan
de l'accident spectaculaire qui a eu
lieu lundi soir entre deux véhicules du
réseau skibus près de la gare de Montini
le Bretonneux les deux bus sont entrés
en collision frontale à 18h42 en roulant
dans le site propre de l'avenue des prê
sur la commune de Montille Bretonneux à
proximité de la gare routière il y avait
un bus qui était sans voyageurs ce bus
qui a percuté l'autre bus qui arrivve
avec voyageur il y
aord et le choc até très violent parmi
les passagers 13 ont été légèrement
blessés l'un des chauffeurs est encore
hospitalisé au chaîné il a un bras cassé
des éclat de verre dans la tête et des
douleurs dans les jambes son pronostic
vital n'est pas engagé c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel deux autobus qui se
percutent sur un site propre non ouvert
la circulation générale c'est tout à
fait exceptionnel je dirais même c'est
déplorable quoi un accident de devrait
pas arriver les bus appartiennent à la
SAVAC exploitant des lignes 461 et 4
du réseau skibus le trafic a repris
normalement ce mardi matin l'enquête est
en cours et devra définir les causes de
l'accident